good night for you guys to kind of end
on a oh wow I know really nice to be
able to finish it off like that
we were getting quite nervous at certain
points we like oh no no it's gonna be so
embarrassing what is that like when the
envelope is about to be open and you're
waiting to hear I mean we have so many
things that you start stressing about we
like we decided that we'd lost because
we were positioned in a certain place
and then sat somewhere else and then we
were when they say Game of Thrones we
just went absolutely berserk but it was
a tense moment we've got a lot of great
video tonight of kind of reunions you
guys haven't seen each other in a while
that's a hugs well wishes what is that
like you know getting back with the
family again and it's this weird thing
was just as you're getting used to
having life after Game of Thrones you
come to an event like this and then you
see all your old friends and you're
something like I really missed this is
life like after Game of Thrones empty
exciting like a brave new world new
chapter so what is this new chapter for
you just finished shooting a movie in
Romania over the summer that will be out
soon and then just seeing seeing what
comes my way for now
[Music]